[Music]
welcome everybody to the premiere
experience in the podcasting world the
h3 podcast experience all other
experiences are lesser to our own this
is the premiere experience today's
episode is sponsored by stitch fix mint
Mabel and empty empty movement i am
ethan klein your grand wizard host of
loneliness last week I was the Wizard of
loneliness ela was supposed to be back
this week she had to delay her return by
another 10 days or so so I've taken on
the title of Grand Wizard of loneliness
not to do with the Klu Klux Klan by the
way just my loneliness I will talk more
about Ella's extended trip
it is quite sad and unfortunate so I
will save that for the end of the show
and I'm not gonna lie to you guys I'm
not wearing underwear today
eel has been gone for three weeks I've
never been away from her for this long
she's finally coming back on Wednesday
ela please come home I am come almost
completely I'm out of underwear I have
no underwear dude I just came out of the
bathroom there's piss drip I'm dribbling
down my leg onto my pants you know what
I'm talking about that's why you wear
underwear right that's the whole point
that it catches your piss I don't have
that protection anymore ela please I
need you with that being said let's get
right into it so I got a really exciting
announcement announcing a new game we've
got here know your meme we're going to
be taking calls today and one very lucky
caller is gonna chance to win a
brand-new slammin hot samsung galaxy s 9
Plus what's the value of that Dan it's
like around $1,000 now we who personally
my favorite phone on the market and if
you can call in and guess 3 out of 5
answers about Joey salads you're gonna
win a brand-new phone here's the number
if you guys think you have what it takes
to know your meme with Joey salads call
eight one eight two one four eight five
zero four we'll be taking that one lucky
caller after the break very very excited
about that
and true we want true salad heads by the
way if you're not a true salad head will
know and Ian will hang the F up on you
quick okay so don't be wasting his time
okay
loving the sound board by the way this
one's dedicated to you EULA but before
I've got a lot I want to talk about
today okay Lucy to Daddy oh five and so
many more goofs and gaffes along the way
but I really like as we did last time I
was in here the trenches by myself you
start off with a great video video of
the day does that have a that work feel
like it was a better the better title I
was thinking video of bliss it's a bit
over the top isn't it video of bliss I'm
gonna think on it but I actually had two
that I thought were so great
I wanted to watch it at the top with you
this one I got to tell you you're gonna
you're gonna love this
I can't I I'm such a skeptic I feel like
part of me thinks this is fake but I
have to believe in my soul and heart
that it's real here we go
this crawfish caught the [ __ ] penny
Oh show that again yeah and that guy's
just like I mean how do you react when
you throw a penny at a crawfish and it
catches it it's claw how do you react
that's pretty much the only way but then
it begs the question why was he filming
to begin with right yeah yeah that's why
are you filming a crawfish on a bathroom
floor and then throwing a penny at it
like what in what world is this
something that you film that makes me
suspicious yet again I've come full
circle that being said I don't know I
feel like it's real it [ __ ] looks
real but I love why why why we need we
need the captain we need the captain
back yeah when the captain disillusion
don't worry but like why would someone
film this I mean what oh it's from
Instagram yeah everything there's fake
anyway I love it regardless and then
there's one other one that I had to
share with you guys this is one of my
favorite videos to come from the
internet in these past weeks this guy
went to City Hall and gave an
impassioned speech not about you know
traffic or politics or whatever city
ordinance tax [ __ ]
you would hear at City Council no this
man came was something much more
important and pressing he came asking
that massage therapist be able to jerk
you off sometimes you got to go with
sometimes you have to go to City Hall to
get to fight for your rights why can't a
massage therapist touch my dick if I pay
her an extra 20 bucks 20 bucks is that
it that's probably a good deal it's
probably more than that
anyway here yeah anyway this guy
obviously says it better than I ever
could so with that you know here you
going seems quiet Dan it's a little
different dude are you why is it
different than you know you're right why
is it different hell we let ask doctors
finger men basically finger men all day
not basically literally literally finger
men's [ __ ] all day
this guy's a hero dude don't question
him I love that his in the crutch of his
argument is what's worse I got to go
back is that really was the argued he's
like it's more nasty for the
proctologist so let just let him jerk
him off right he's saying what's the
difference you're already getting in the
folds when I just touched his dick along
the way compelling argument I'd like to
see a counterpoint made to that
right right
hey man brother what a patriot right Wow
Wow full circle right there
amen brother that guy's definitely a
comedian right he's got the socks and
sandals that would truly be a happy
ending for everyone
[ __ ] amen brother Danny fuer
have you ever had got a massage like
like a full-body Swedish massage Dan I
have not I have seriously yeah never
done it I was gonna ask if like I've
gotten a couple times but I was [ __ ]
applause sound effect I was gonna ask if
it's ever moved when you were getting a
massage I mean I can't say in a
professional setting I mean you know
obviously in private that's a different
that's a different tale altogether but
no I it's it's too weird I don't know I
have like I have a some time I'm just
saying it sometimes it moves sure I mean
it's a natural what are you gonna do can
you do anyway god bless - this guy Ian
has it ever moved for you have you ever
had a massage in he's off at set right
now he's starting sprinkles all right
ah God let's just say that he has though
okay um so anyway I salute this Patriot
and I'm all about it all right but that
being said let's get let's get into them
the main event here fouseytube I feel
like it's like a repeat almost of last
week when we talked about Connie tannic
on just trying to decode and explain
what's happened so fussy fouseytube if
you guys don't know who he is he's a he
began as a prankster and he faked
a lot of pranks he almost he invented
almost like the moral the righteous fake
prank where it was like what was the
example you gave me dan where he had one
more oh yeah he's like he stands in the
street and he's yelling at people for
not having like their seatbelt on or
something I don't know just like he's
always got to have like a moral twist on
it he kind of invented that whole thing
so anyway he fell off I'm pretty sure
he's been having a lot of mental issues
and it seems like he's in a full-blown
manic state right now I mean he let's
start here let's start from the top yeah
he says with two million viewers Drake
is going to grace the stage of my
concert he's only got two thousand likes
that seems like a far away off two
million views
anyway he keeps saying that Drake's
gonna be at a show Drake's gonna be at a
show he's never he never talked to Drake
he's ever known Drake he's he sells out
the Greek a free show and he says
Drake's gonna be there and obviously
Drake never shows up
but basically what ensues is a lot of
insanity a lot of confusion and a very
little crowd and him stalking Drake
which is probably the best and I mean
the best the most entertaining and
concerning thing to come out of this
whole thing this video pretty much sums
it all up for me let me throw this up
here for you this this video really has
it all its got stalking it's got a
Jarama let's hear it
quiet dant can you turn it up
yep got you to the people by the way
he's taking this clip from someone
else's show an upload this is a video on
his channel right now so to put it in
frame here so that this is when it gets
really good so I think he probably spent
about $100,000 reserving the Greek and I
will say to his credit I mean I don't
want to compare it to Tana Kong because
what Tana did was basically sell
supposedly free tickets and didn't even
give on the event or refund people his
was free so at least there's there's the
a big separation to be made there I mean
he's not scamming people he's just
misleading people but it's a free show
but what's really fascinating is just
his clear mental decline here watch this
is he is he I mean I can't tell if he's
just like cracked out or if he's just on
a manic rant yeah it it seems very manic
yeah it seems very American and isn't he
he publicly has a history of that does
he not he yes yeah he's bipolar he said
right so I just yeah I don't know I
think people give fousey well let's keep
watching let's get the whole frame of
reference here
great I'm trying to find some thought of
item I'd like this please so tomorrow
we've had theater I love that he
included that I don't know who it was I
don't even know if it was a police
officer could have just been normal guy
who's just like [ __ ] this idiot
get back in your car he goes from being
like a total badass to being like oh I'm
sorry dude it's or nothing but he leaves
it in which I find curious he clearly
could have edited that out
he finished his statement but he got and
I and I hate to say this but he got
cooked a little bit by whoever was on
the street you know what I mean and he
left that in find the interesting now
this is when it get takes a really dark
twist I mean first of all dude if
there's a setting for any video talking
to a celebrity this is him I mean look
at look at this frame he's mean dude
this is straight out of like a horror
movie like are you in my basement right
now foo see I mean listen what he says
he's got the dongles hanging out those
dongles are not a good look for anybody
by the way let alone a celebrity stalker
but let's watch cool you've acknowledged
stop there I literally look and I'm
acting like a crazy person right now cuz
I'm outside of the house you're at stop
there dude you just you just summarized
it but he knows that it's not actually
crazy even though it is
don't ask me how I found it
I've got ways creepy creepy ways you're
probably wondering how did I find you
you're probably wondering to yourself
right now how did I find you and do I
need to call the police and get a
restraining order do I need to have my
bodyguards bodyguards escort them out
you're probably wondering don't worry
about that don't worry it's interesting
how we on one hand acknowledges all this
how creepy he's being right and on the
other hand fully committed it seems so
manic is it doesn't see yeah doesn't
seem like he's intoxicated or like on
drugs or anything he's very clear-headed
about it it's just nuts
well symptoms of a manic episode I mean
here let's read it off abnormally upbeat
jumpy or wired boom increased activity
energy or agitation boom exaggerated
self sense of well-being and
self-confidence yes unusually talkative
racing thoughts distractibility I mean
yeah yep it's extras the little layer of
creepy that he keeps playing that God's
plan loop this is like such a creepy
stalker video of like a weird fan
food.if who see ends up killing Drake
I'll be like 10% surprised God's plan
baby you might be thinking to yourself
he's like over him Drake's sleeping in
his bed and foo sees like hovering over
him you might think this is a little
strange Drake but this is God's plan for
me to murder you right now in fact if
you look down you'll notice is already a
knife in your stomach I mean you know
what he does meanwhile he's got on his
phone God's plan looping
God's plan little bit psycho and God's
plan
damn damn he's he's gonna come down to
earth and cut in like I don't know how I
don't know how long manic episodes last
but he's gonna be like oh I don't know
if Uzi he's an interesting guy like I
don't know if I feel bad for him in a
way because it's like he's it's it's
such a strange situation with him
because he has a fan base like when
you're when you're having a manic
episode and having delusions of grandeur
the fact that he actually has a fan base
and people encouraging him right that
makes it all so much more [ __ ] dot so
much worse he's just enables his
delusions it's crazy
can you imagine how [ __ ] having a
30-second conversation this never
happened I promise that this event is
gonna be huge but I need you for it to
be huge it's like yeah [ __ ] obviously
he doesn't need you though
unfortunately he goes one way I'm like
I'm like listen guys I'm putting on the
hugest show of the year all I need is
two POC and biggie to return from the
grave and co-host it with me and it's
gonna be the biggest concert ever put on
yeah sick hype bro how long to take you
to make that and premiere oh hey now my
video can get copyrighted just [ __ ] me
up
thanks really thanks foo see you're
[ __ ] all of our monetization up now
now I got beef with you
where's my mouse so he uploaded on his
channel
I mean it's still up of him literally
here's a this always trips me out when I
can see myself it's still up of him
publicly stalking a celebrity on his
channel which just shows you how unaware
he is of how strange is his behaviors so
that's that's where that's kind of where
it began he's now withdrawn from from
the internet right I don't know he's
retreated back into into his cave yeah I
don't know he he he posted a diss track
on rice gum which I find strange like I
clearly acting's not working out for
your dog that was a pretty corny read
clear clearly acting uh not working out
for me like I just acted that out better
than him when I was trying to act that
can I and that was really Khaled on the
phone crazy crazy so anyway it's just
it's really just another YouTube hip-hop
fit it you guys seen a thousand of these
rap video but what I found fascinating
about this was the vision board here let
me play for a second just so you can
kind of put into perspective what he
hoped for this song
it's a rice gum district so anyway you
get that I mean really get the idea
that's all you need to see so his vision
for this rice come district is number
one song on Billboard Hot 100 can you
imagine the country banking to a race
come dis track 350 million views in
under three months when what [ __ ]
planet it's a race come dis track bro
like if you wanted to actually make an
accessible song why would you just write
it about anything else club banger on
radio in the entire world at least once
a day manifest your dreams just as I did
man I swear to god I'm I feel like I'm
entering the mind of madness reading
this help each other achieve each
other's dream kill your ego you got a
long way to go there buddy
so I thought that was pretty pretty cute
pretty interesting well guys I mean we
can get it there we got to get this on
top billboard number one I'm sure it's
really close it's climbing it's climbing
fast god I really need a look back I
need a live a kid next week next week
next week baby Wednesday no [ __ ]
underwear I always joke about people
getting [ __ ] stains I'm like who gets
[ __ ] stands I'm in pants with [ __ ] and
piss inside of it I'll show you if you
don't believe me there's little [ __ ]
streaks
I've got shmegmer building up on my
penis I didn't have foreskin Eva changes
my diaper and cleans my dick telling you
ela please come back where was I event
yada yada yada
he holds the event at the Greek a free
show how many C's does a Greek have like
10,000 not quite where's this video okay
whatever
Greek holds I believe around
six or seven thousand okay pretty big
show so this this is my favorite thing
cut so this is the show it's happening
the fousey hasn't even showed up but
this this is the [ __ ] crowd I mean
what is that like 20 people there at the
stage and this DJ man god bless his soul
crushing it huh look at the employees
they're like what is this like these
guys are you still like assuring like
huge so how depends what the [ __ ] is
this I swear to God food CMOS I I mean
getting the Greek we were gonna spend
twenty five thousand just to rent out
the ACE which is a two thousand seat
theater right that was twenty five
thousand this on all this [ __ ] I'd say
at least a hundred thousand he spent on
this yeah and I mean the Greek is it's
an iconic venue it's very very much in
demand yeah it's not not cheap well on a
weekend - oh yeah on a weekend damn yeah
that's that's a pretty penny right there
it's trying to hype up the crowd
well I don't know man you're mixing
doesn't sound that good I love that even
the DJs in on this ludus delusion
what if Drake just walked on stage right
now to the hundred of you huddled around
the stage he'd be so mad no dude it's
because you not drink
killing it brushing it damn that's a
that is a coal to crowd my dudes that
that's the vibe there there's basically
nobody there and then someone calls it
because it's live-streaming it's got
like 60,000 views he said he was gonna
get two million Drake was gonna come out
there's like a thousand people there
sixty thousand people watching online
that's kind of a lot to be honest but I
think most people are watching just for
the beautiful train wreck that they knew
it was gonna be and somebody called a
bomb threat which is just like cherry on
top I mean it's like I'm not surprised
I'm not surprised there are conspiracy
theories and I have to say they're
compelling because you always have to
ask yourself who benefits the most from
this crime bomb threats called could
totally be anyone on the internet I mean
that is a that's a juicy mean but a
fousey called the bomb threat he wasn't
at the venue yet he was waiting to see
how big it got if Drake would just I
don't know what he thinks happen if like
Drake was just like materialized he's
like two million I'm here but if he
called it in himself I wonder if he was
able to get a refund to be like oh man
the show never happened or oh I have to
be embarrassed because Drake never
showed up you know what I'm saying he
kind of benefited the most from that
bomb threat which is why it's a
compelling conspiracy theory and I'm not
saying that how dare you say I would
never say or implicate or say and it
make any statement like that there's an
opinion you know what I'm saying there's
a thought experiment I'm merely asking
questions I've been through enough
lawsuits one by the way and that's
plenty that's plenty
there is some sense in it you know I
mean he benefit he really he did frankly
I can see him benefiting from that bomb
threat but like you said I mean
you know people get swatted all the time
they literally could be somebody else
just generally yeah easily whoever was
by the way [ __ ] that person and I hope
they get caught if it does end up being
food soup wouldn't that be like the
greatest twist in this epic saga ever am
i explaining this to people
understanding this making sense who
gives a [ __ ] it's all so stupid there's
just another thing of like YouTube is
just devolved into such like why is he
famous you know what I mean like YouTube
is YouTube has turned into this like
engine for creating Fame for people who
should never had even a taste of Fame
the most fousey should have ever been
famous for his stockinged rake like
there's so many people and when you give
Fame in like because Fame it has it has
a lot of power and frankly a lot of
responsibility that comes with that and
when you give it to somebody like that
and many others on YouTube it's like
you're giving a bazooka to a monkey Lucy
should not be famous man so many other
people the Khans Tanna should not be
famous my god
Tanna should be working at Wendy's
specifically Wendy she does the other
fast foods for some reason don't ring
true to me she should be serving up
Wendy's and yet here she is you know
well she might be serving on burgers in
prison pretty soon somebody's got to
cook them you think they get burgers in
prison maybe I think they probably do
that's pretty dope it doesn't sound that
bad after all I don't know this is why
I'm like I feel like I don't I don't
like I love the podcast coz I I really
feel like we're doing our own thing but
I just feel like youtuber is becoming
and YouTube itself is just like what is
this it's like always the same [ __ ] like
this is [ __ ] stupid
I'm I've been talking about this I got
to finish this story though it's reality
show you know it's the same I guess
right but it's almost I mean maybe it's
not worse I don't know I guess you're
right it is the same impulse but people
look at Kim Kardashian I mean I guess a
lot of people look to them as role
models I guess it's the same kind of
Danna
not that I know so then basically the
bomb threat shuts this whole [ __ ] down
and he shows up gets on his gets on a
car of his uber drivers was fired by the
way after this so good he's like I'll
give you he said this isn't the video
but I'm not gonna bother showing it to
cuz it's like come on give me a [ __ ]
break
but he says I'll give you $50,000 if you
let me stand on your car and deliver a
monologue to everybody and he's like
okay you know so it goes on the car he
makes him hit a blunt he gets fired
obviously and then Lucy's sharing their
text messages of the uber driver being
like dude I got fired I really need this
job I need the money and he's like talk
to my accountant my accountants gonna
hook you up whatever I can't tell if
that's flab or six-pack he's got it
rolled up though why does he have it
rolled up what is you're already wearing
a wife-beater it's the most a breathable
shirt you can possibly wear so it's like
it makes it look like he's wearing a
sports bra it does got some nice titties
boy there's some support right
I can tell his flab or its muscle but
he's real
hold up just take it off I mean take off
the [ __ ] shirt at that point your
you've gone 70% of the way training bra
you've got a training bra on for some
luscious breasts you've been grilling it
sounds weird to say up training bra and
luscious breasts next to each other you
know I mean there's like ten years apart
let's move on I love that line it's
really not a great insult heating up my
breath
you're heating up your breakfast well
anyway let's watch this [ __ ] I'm you
know don't drag this out too much by the
way his event is called like hate thighs
Love Wins or whatever I've arrived yeah
and he just gets on this car and he's
[ __ ] talking [ __ ] to everybody [ __ ]
you well to be fair he there's a lot of
love sprinkled in there seemingly at
random to little love a little hate no
he should call his vent a little love a
little hey that would have been accurate
I would have accepted that is a more
accurate just coming to throw a
convention call a little love little
hate it's a balanced meal anyway this
this is an image of a man on the verge
of a complete you know this reminds me
of remember the Kony guy the Kony guy he
became the biggest meme on the internet
right then he was jerking off at the
corner some corner in San Diego mm-hmm
he was like the most important guy and
then he was jerking off in public
[ __ ] is a couple is a couple stressful
days away from full-blown masturbating
in public I mean I wouldn't be at all
surprised if he whipped out his dick
right now on that car he's just sharing
the love did
now that's what I call love arriving
give me three seconds my love is about
to arrive baby anyway you get the
[ __ ] idea who gives a [ __ ] yeah
anyway I really for me he's he's having
a mental breath there's really no
question about it definitely he's he is
bipolar and he said that so the do needs
help he needs intervention man he needs
someone who loves him and cares about
him to step in and be like dude let's
wrap this up before you get your dick
out in public cuz there's no going back
once you go that far absolutely yeah the
top of this week when we heard about all
of this and I started investigating it I
was laughing my ass off I thought was
hilarious in the mirror I watched the
laughter was fading as well oh this is
this is actually kind of sad this event
is called the the laughter dies and the
concern arises all right let's take a
quick break we got we're gonna come back
with know your meme featuring Joey
salads I'm so excited to play this game
we've got two all prepared
Joey himself has recorded answers so you
are not gonna want to miss this guy's
see you soon it's hard enough to dress
myself let's be honest
especially with Iligan it's impossible
talk about going to a store buying stuff
making decisions it's it's unfathomable
that's why stitch fix is changing the
game so convenient stitch fix is an
online site you go you tell them your
style your preferences your budget and
they have a stylus that will pick out
clothing for you based on your
preferences and send it to you tailored
for you you don't have to go to the
store you don't have to pick anything
out you don't have to worry about it
you got people with taste to do that for
you and let's be frank most of us most
of us guys we can't dress ourselves we
are completely helpless I'm gonna be
frank with you guys right now I am not
wearing underwear
because ILA's been gone for three weeks
and I haven't done laundry I'm just
sayin and not all of us have us and for
the rest of us that's stitch fix they've
reinvented how we buy clothes you just
answer a few questions on size
preference budget boom you're going
stylus springs into action hand
selecting five brand new clothing items
just for you the styling fee is only 20
bucks which is applied as a credit
towards anything you keep and since it
is based on your preference you're still
in control it's not your mom taking over
here okay once your items arrive you try
them on and here's the best part you
only pay for what you keep so really
they're sending you closer to try on and
if you like it you keep it and you buy
it and if you don't you send it back
come on guys
it doesn't get any better than that so
get your fix whenever you want or sign
up to receive scheduled shipments the
choice is yours
so my dudes head on over to stitch fix
dot-com slash h3 to get started right
now keep all five items in your box and
you'll get 25% off your entire purchase
that's stitch fix calm slash h3 stitch
fix calm slash h3 it's convenient it is
gonna make you look and feel like a
trillion bucks and you got nothing to
lose because you can return it if you
don't like it thank you stitch fix very
excited about our new sponsor mint
mobile which is changing the game on
cellular phone plans now let me give you
a little anecdote when I was in Israel
and me and hello were really broke
barely getting by
there was companies that was doing like
these guys did and it saved our ass what
these guys offer is basically an exit
from these normal giants like AT&T and
Verizon and everyone else because these
guys will cut your wireless bill down to
15 bucks a month instead of instead of
what 50 to 100 bucks I mean mobile it's
so freakin expensive it should be $15 a
month and these guys are gonna get you
there mint mobile is proving to millions
of Americans that getting your wireless
bill doesn't have to be the worst day of
the month they make it so easy to cut
the wireless bill down to just 15
dollars you
your own phone with any meant mobile
plant you can keep your old number along
with all of your existing contracts and
you choose between two five or ten
gigabyte 4G LTE plans there's no you
don't have to pay for an unlimited data
plan that you're never gonna use every
plan comes with unlimited talk and text
so you can safely and cheaply annoy all
your friends and loved ones I hope my
mom doesn't get this plan and get it
because she calls me a lot just one of
those jokes and if you're not 100%
satisfied mint mobile has you covered
with their seven day money-back
guarantee outfox your old wireless bill
and start saving with mint mobile listen
guys 15 bucks you it's it's the same
[ __ ] it's in this day and age is not
like oh can you hear me now it's the
same [ __ ] everyone's got good reception
15 bucks a month I'm telling you this
[ __ ] is gonna change everything for you
to get your new wireless plan for just
$15 a month plus free shipping on your
mint Mobile SIM card go to mint
mobile.com slash h3 that's mint
mobile.com slash h3 cut your wireless
bill to 15 bucks a month and get free
shipping on your mint Mobile SIM card
mint mobile comm / h3 and the empty
movement watches are the greatest
watches on the market and the cheapest
price how do they do that they cut out
the middleman and do it themselves don't
take my word for it take it from the
almost two million people that have
bought watches in 160 countries and they
continue to revolutionize the market
check this out
they've come from being crowdfunded kids
working out of a living room the past
years they not only introduced a ton of
new watch collections for both men and
women and also expanded into sunglasses
and fashion forward bracelets for her
they keep making new new products look
at this is their new one right here this
is the revolver I got to tell you I like
it I want I want one of these look at
this black one dude slick as hell it's
like what the [ __ ] is up now haters
that's what I would that's what it says
to me and this is what I frankly like
this okay
it's a
watch it tells the time and it looks
good it's not blowing up my wrist ela
always sending me nudes give me a break
you know what I mean it's a watch that's
what it does it looks good so movement
watches start at just $95 at a
department store you're looking at four
to five hundred to five thousand a
million dollars in department stores but
these guys 95 bucks classic design
quality construction styled minimalist
again don't take it from me
take it from the two million people that
are wearing this right now and getting
tons of people touching their dick
probably tons of that so get 15% because
the watch looks so good they're just
like oh [ __ ] let me grab your dick not
in a sexual assault way just like oh my
god it's like you want it and then they
touch it it's not like a crime get 15%
off today with free shipping and free
returns by going to nvm t.com / h3 cyn
VMT keeps growing check out their
expanding collection go to and VMT
dot-com / h3 and join the flippin
movement welcome back everyone to the
experience I miss us so much god I wish
it wasn't [ __ ] my [ __ ] diaper right
now I you know what I feel like feel
like Bo Anil is my Papa I should tell
you got we were goofing around on
Twitter a little bit that Drake was
gonna be here where that's not real he I
just I have to stalk him a little bit
later I have somebody I have a bunch of
goons stalking him right now so if we
can get up to a hundred thousand live
viewers on the stream right now I don't
know what we're at but Drake will as I
understand it from fousey he will
basically materialize into the podcast
studio so you know tell everybody to
tune in so I just told I'm really
excited for love to arrive I should tell
you guys by the way that fousey
reached out to me yesterday I almost had
him on the show today I almost had him
on he reached out to me and said
something like only you can cut through
the [ __ ] if you ever want me on like
said he'd save himself for you he said
that his virginity I mean you want
should we find out I see I wonder if
he's into giving happy endings which is
every American's god-given right you
should take all of this manic energy he
has and go he's not gonna at the City
Council meeting get all that manic
energy and put it into rubbing my dick
anyway he can't he contacted me and I
almost had him on but I was like I I
don't know
I'm I miss my I feel like with ela gone
I gotta play it straight I get into
trouble when he was gone you she's back
home dealing with some really heavy-duty
stuff I got a good do it straight I
wanted to talk about what's going on
with ela so I was I don't I don't want
that circus coming in here and and like
I don't really care that much fun being
honest you know I mean really good until
I mean what's there to say yeah what's
her to say the guy's insane really he's
a lunatic right there's not really
anything more a breakdown than that you
know
alright let's go let's get on with it no
you're mean guys alright here we go here
we go I'm excited you guys are gonna
love this
I really we we put effort okay so here
we go
welcome everybody to know your meme the
first episode featuring Joey salads do
you know your meme let's find out with
our first caller Dan the music seems too
loud okay I mean it sounds good
on the stream but I'll pull you there
let's take our first call
Laura Laura you're on the air how are
you Laura
keep it together we're playing a game
here alright are you ready to play know
your meme
all right here we go question number one
all right let me turn this music off to
get a bit much
Joey's most embarrassing recorded act is
it a his dick pics leaked online be
pinging in his own mouth or seed being
caught race baiting fake pranks go ahead
what do you think a B or C take you this
is based on his own answer peeing in his
own mouth is that final answer alright
hit us with it Dan what is his answer
damn really good try really really good
try I would have guessed peeing in his
mouth
that's embarrassing for most people but
sadly Joey is a host to many
embarrassing moments and you were very
close so based by the way you need three
points we've got five questions so all
hope is not lost okay you're good so
we're moving on to number two okay what
does Joey salads like most about Donald
Trump is it a his policies B his swagger
or C
his hate for Hillary Clinton take your
time well stop getting the mind of Joey
salad enter the mind of madness swagger
is that your final answer
go ahead and roll it that's right
Swagger's correct all right Joe you take
you explaining to I yeah yeah we got it
we got it
yeah that is correct his attitude his
swagger you have crew you have
successfully gotten the mind of salad
and you're doing great
you've got one point you need two more
we've got three more questions okay you
feel how are you feeling feeling
confident you're holding it down you're
doing great here we go question three
what percentage of Joey salads pranks
are faked a 50/50 B they're all fake
or C they're all real enter the mind of
salad take your time
a B they're all fake that's a debt
that's a very definite answer it's all
answer well take cube take a moment
think about it
[Music]
Jenny 10 cents man running out you have
10 seconds on the clock
a B or C 50/50 your final answer is it
50/50 Dan congratulations Laura you are
just one correct answer away from this
brand new Galaxy S 9 plus do you need
this phone will you cherish and enjoy
this phone that's a good answer
it's a really good answer alright
there's two more left you only need two
ones needs one right you know we got
this we got this okay what is Joey
salads real last name is it a salah' T
no cell a teeny oh sorry Sal a teeny Oh
B salad or C Saladino take your time
that's a tricky one Salatin yo salad or
Saladino enter the mind of salad what
does your heart say
[Music]
let the final answer to the mind
meditate you have one more chance so
don't stress but we are running low on
the clock what is your answer
saladin oh is it Saladino dan do we have
any winning music Dan we've been winning
music I guess it's a little salad do you
know that is 3 correct congratulations
you're a winner we've got one bonus
question
if and let's just say it let's do this
ok cuz I you know we've got these
answers from Joey they're all terrific
so let's do this if you get this wrong
you lose the phone no I'm kidding I
won't do that to you I'm kidding
but let's just play it let's just play
it for fun alright if you get this right
we're gonna include some swag some extra
swag
you're gonna love crazy [ __ ] dude it's
ranges Drake basically Drake's gonna
show up to your house mm-hmm
are you I don't know if he'll do
anything you want literally talked about
it so that's what I'm offering you is
yeah I don't know if you're into that
but that's what's on the table what no
no no he's coming with much more than
singing okay so there's really nothing
on this table but I love the tension so
let's melt it Joey
what is Joey salads favorite type of
salad dressing is it a ranch be Italian
or see does he hate salad itself and a
stunning
you're confident a true fan hmm a true
listener hmm I like you very much Laura
and I'm glad we're giving you this phone
because gee I have to say Dan what is
the answer yes you are the ultimate
winner Laura crushing no you're mean
coming through with a staggering four
points out of five this brand-new
Samsung Galaxy S nine plus is yours
unreal and Drake is gonna come he's
gonna sing for you and so much more and
that's my personal guarantee do dan how
do we keep her on the line can we pass
her over to Ian to get our details yes
we will yeah stay on the line and we'll
stay on the line Laura thank you for the
first winner of know your meme everyone
give a round of applause that was a lot
of fun thank you very much and God bless
you god bless all right all right I
think that went pretty well
hey that was a lot of fun we were
worried that people wouldn't be you know
up to snuff on the flora Joey trivia she
entered the mine of salad four out of
five was stressful when she missed the
first one which is kind of exciting yeah
yeah know that there was ups and downs
oh my god we got it gutters I want to do
one with like Ethan Bradberry and Moe
hmm yeah I got to think who else would
be really good at this but that was that
was a blast
I'll do the Bradbury's we could do we
could do mr. Antonio Bradbury farms
forever guys I want to look back in
Memorial today daddy of five as you all
know was the great and wonderful
youtuber who filmed himself abusing both
physically and verbally his children for
the amusement of everyone on YouTube and
if I can continue my thesis of youtubers
being garbage that shouldn't be famous
he is really the main exhibit there here
you have a man like if we can pull up
just an image so that you all know
kind of what I'm talking about here you
have a man white trash as as as humanly
possible who has found fame and fortune
on YouTube daddy of five I mean give it
up I mean there's nowhere else in the
planet where a man like this ladies and
gentlemen a man like this could ever
find Fame look at that he he and his
wife who won't say much but man she is
something him and his wife we're abusing
their kids actually had quite a fan base
half a million subscribers hundreds of
thousands of views on every video and
there was one that really crossed the
line the police got involved
they actually they're convicted for
child neglect he had some kids from a
previous marriage right they were
removed they were removed yes right and
he was convicted from for child neglect
and his first channel was shut down but
being the Intuit that I won't say the
industrious the ingenuity the great
daddy-o 5 rebranded himself he returned
triumphantly to YouTube under the flag
of family of five beautiful he's back
he's been back at it for several months
until recently his name came up again
and I'm sad to say after posting another
video of abusing his poor son who I'm
sure and I hate to say this about his
son is probably gonna shoot up a school
in five years and I don't enjoy saying
that but I would I mean I keep an eye on
that kid and I appreciate I mean I know
that I've been through a lot and I love
that kid he's a sweet guy but when you
make your kid dress like this this kid's
name is Cody this kids [ __ ] they just
bully on this poor kid he's like man
it's crazy
they make him wear glasses with like
look at this [ __ ]
they make him wear these glasses and
it's got like the tail
so he can't drop them but it's like
really tight around his head
and you cannot wear the sunglasses
protectors and not get your ass beat all
the time you guys know what I'm talking
about why the [ __ ] bro why the [ __ ] is
the god of cringe blowing up Google
Images talk about someone's who's
challenged should be erased this guy's
sitting naked in the [ __ ] Google
Images I'm trying to run a show here he
got me the god of cringe he got you he
[ __ ] he got boo me
how is he so high in the ranking for
daddy of five I don't get that anyway
he's back it came up again and YouTube
finally has said daddy a five more like
daddy of not having a channel Wow
[ __ ] roasted crickets on that one so
I thought we would look back and cherish
the moments we had together so this is
from him one of his new channels
actually I thought you guys might enjoy
this once again Cody is the subject of
his ridicule the title of the video this
is a reupload dad destroys sons Nintendo
DS and well I don't know about you but
that's pretty much the title of a loving
family if I've ever heard long
absolutely
only on YouTube can you enjoy actual
child abuse on the many fine tastes
available here among many others this is
like an episode of police except
nobody's arresting him by the way and
his crime his crime is that he just
keeps taking his dad's D s and playing
it this kid nothing better to do in his
life
what wants to play his dad's D s when
he's not using it [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
that need nerd needs to go down and
guess who's gonna be the one to do it
his dad hosted so this is just the
screeching [ __ ] war zone and hundreds
of thousands of views this is good [ __ ]
this is good [ __ ] dan his wife sounds
like the [ __ ] Wicked Witch by the way
I was like unlike I mean listen to this
piece of work what are you cooking kids
she's got a crazy voice man I got to
tell you if you could make the most
white-trash hick ass hillbilly [ __ ] and
sin they wouldn't compete with family of
five I got guys
can you imagine your dad screaming at
you like that so you know everyone in
his school is watching this dude
sometimes you got a teacher can a lesson
the worst part is like oh it's somehow
they drunk that he's putting on a good
show
damn this guy must have the emotional
maturity of like a real 12 year I mean
he's bowling imagine bowling your own
kids like not like being rough with them
or tough with them actually bullying
your own child and then and then sitting
down at a computer with that footage
editing and editing it well dan I have
to tell you you're gonna appreciate
where this goes because his editing
comes into play in a really terrific way
it's an accent you know okay the best
editing is usually invisible you know
this videos is marinated finally all
right someone save this poor child it
looks like a merc he looks oh yeah you
terribly yeah yeah yeah yeah II imagine
that's your dad I feel like he's putting
it on for the video too but he can't
tell the difference the kid certainly
can't you know no same to them
he's thinking right now this is good
drama again some good [ __ ] right now
I've squeezed some good drama out of
these kids right now teach him a lesson
teach that little piece of [ __ ] nice you
got him good man really good it gets
good it gets really good there's a scene
I want to find a great scene he goes to
uh the scene where he goes to the garage
and starts hitting it with a mallet
notice his brother flank jump kicking
him in the head with no intervention
from his parents he goes through the
garage with a mallet and starts smashing
it where's that well regardless this is
when it gets really good down this is
what I was referring to I hope you enjoy
this editing feat wow I really wonder
why so poorly adjusted to the world I
don't know man I just thought if I had a
kid and beat the [ __ ] out of him in Yoda
and all the time and destroyed his stuff
he'd grow up to be a good kid I'm gonna
work for him right yeah he died great
yeah
okay he edited and sad [ __ ] music and
cherished this when I heard that I was
like no [ __ ] way put that in he's a
guard away it's not for him it's not for
Cody it's for the dad the dad's heart is
broken
I see but watch you'll see he lays it
down alright we've seen enough Cody it's
about you know watch he's suffering
being a dad of five is tough sometimes
you have to discipline your kids for the
greater good because they're liars and
they're thief's by no fault of your own
life stuff and you need sad music to
help the audience understand how
stressful life is and you're gonna act
really sad and upset Wow very
consciously putting on vlog camera yeah
thank you
make sure the framings nice let's let's
forget it was to his selfie camera work
there though well here good he's a pro
but I have to say let's let's definitely
forget that he's holding a vlog camera
on one hand pointed at his face
while having a breakdown in the other
hand damn that music is really
gut-wrenching
and I feel so bad he's so sympathetic
yeah I feel so bad for this daddy-o five
he's forlorn oh oh he doesn't care about
the camera anymore how long he's gonna
care fade to black
he died listen his torture room man if
you thought he's a shitty guy listen
where is he I had to do it it really
hurts him and upsets him that he had to
do that and you got it anyway [ __ ]
good riddance you [ __ ] psychopath
[ __ ] that guy
god damn this is okay again this guy's
famous on YouTube this guy has made a
healthy living on YouTube and I get I
don't know what my point is because
there's plenty of legit people on
YouTube too but um well in he's gone now
what I don't understand why was he a
while back yeah I don't know he is it
the family of five channel after being a
convicted child neglect er was allowed
to continue I don't know I don't know
but they just shut it down finally so
who knows who knows I mean I guess
better late than never but [ __ ]
so give it up to daddy of five rest in
peace I fear blip when he loses his
livelihood I fear for what will become
of that family speaking frankly well
we're at the bottom of the show and I
had mentioned at the top of the show
that um heelas alou's dealing with some
stuff back home and I didn't want to
talk about it cuz it's really happy but
I do want to talk about it right now is
that Ella's dad passed away about I
guess it was probably like three or four
days ago now
so it's great it's so crazy like she
went there for two weeks she planned to
go there for two weeks and when she went
there he was it wasn't fine he was
terminally ill but I mean nobody
expected that he was gonna die during
her stay there like he he picked her up
from the airport it's just I don't know
it's been it's been really a wild ride
for her I mean she knew her dad was like
terminally ill but like the day she
arrived they were giving him radiation
treatment because his lung cancer has
spread to his brain and the doctor was
like we really need to kill this tumor
with radiation the chance of success is
really high and it takes eight weeks for
it to work so they and a week after that
he [ __ ] passed away it was just so
crazy man like I don't know she's been
she's been going through a lot and I do
want to say about Ella's dad I have
talked about him on this podcast a
couple of times some wonderful moments
I'll say fondly now because they were
always kind of like not taken very
seriously the first great one being that
he told me he said ela don't ever let
Ethan come in this house if he's coming
over here with socks and sandals that
was my move back then I was wearing not
just like sliders but flip-flops the one
with the string in the middle so I was
wearing a white sock all the way up and
the string like shoving the sock in it
was not a good look
and frankly I understand it's
embarrassing this is my son-in-law I
thought it was funny but he was serious
and frankly he's a he's an old-school
guy he's all about respect and integrity
but I didn't wear sandals to house again
and frankly I don't do that anymore
because it is pretty insane way to walk
around the world so I can if I can in
retrospect
appreciate
that that was a changing point for me
straighten you out the next great moment
Jochen on moment was um god we've told
the story but it's like back in the day
when we first started YouTube there was
this one video called shake that dick
and it was so obscene when I can't watch
it's so vulgar and like our videos
weren't particularly vulgar but this is
the one for some reason the one that he
actually saw and it was a parody of
shake that ass
and it was the lots of close-ups of me
wearing like basketball shorts without
underwear shaking my dish was disgusting
and obscene and he saw a that's the one
he had to see and he says ela if you
guys keep making videos like this I will
I'm gonna disown Ethan from being my
son-in-law and once again I I get it you
know I don't know why that had to be the
one but that's the one but that's he's a
guy that was all about he's old school
he's all about respect and integrity and
upholding the family name but I have to
say he was he was always good to me I
mean when I when we moved to Israel from
America he's like a really old-school
dude he let me move in with them he had
never met me before and he let me come
and stay with them and sleep in their
house and he always treated me well and
he always welcomed me and he fed me and
he gave me a chance to to be there and
work there and make it work with ela and
he definitely could have been like weird
guy coming saying my house I mean that's
that was a huge stretch for him but it
definitely
me definitely gave us a chance that that
made it all work but it's for it there
was something that ela told me that was
like really
I guess heartbreaking in a way not
really but nice is that you know he from
that moment where he was like Warsaw
shake that dick at the funeral ever all
of his friends and family were telling
yo that he was yeah he was telling all
of the friends and family how proud he
was of her and us in particular of what
we we had accomplished since then and
they were saying like he was always
bragging about you guys sharing your
videos on Facebook talking about you and
with everybody and we unfriended him
after the the shake that dick thing
because we're like all right we can't
you can't be seeing these well we didn't
even know every time we posted a podcast
or video or a post or whatever he was
really was sharing it on his own
Facebook page to his family his all
school traditional conservative family
this was like the last picture they took
to get together like right when you went
in the hospital was like a week left and
he's got a big-ass [ __ ] smile on his
face and he's rocking that Teddy fresh
and he's basically one week from death I
mean he's in pain all the time and like
I don't know just the fact that he
mustered that big smile for EULA rocking
that Teddy fresh I mean he was he was a
great one he was a true supporter and he
really enabled us to to thrive and
succeed in Israel I know I got thinking
about like I've been thinking a lot
about just this whole concept of like
saying goodbye it's like we're always
it's like it's so hard like we're not
ready we're not trained at all like we
don't ever think about death or like how
to say goodbye to loved ones or even for
us to say goodbye we don't confront
death it's always like swept under the
rug and my bandmate and my really good
friend Isaac's mom also passed away
suddenly earlier this year so we made a
little song that we dedicated to Ella's
dad and Isaac's mom so that's the end of
the show I hope you guys enjoy the song
thanks for watching
[Music]
everyone can say hello everyone knows I
say hello
to leave you ways to say goodbye I'll
see you on the other side everybody know
[Music]
the place we're all bound to go nobody
knows nobody knows
[Music]
to say goodbye I'll see you on the other
side everybody know everyone knows today
is just a day buried in the blanket of
time he taught me how to say hello
didn't teach me how to say good
goodbye is just a pile of stone
I walk along a row of stone everyone
knows
the row of star
to see you and to say goodbye laid
across the moon that side everybody know
I see you when I close my eyes
nobody knows nobody know when the dream
will fade away I walk along the roads
you think everybody
everyone knows today is just a day
buried in the blanket of time you taught
me how to say hello they teach me how to
say goodbyes just a pile of stone
goodbye just a pile of star
[Music]
you
you